welcome to the reason live stream I'm
Zach Weissmuller joined by my colleague
Nick Gillespie and Emma Ashford a senior
fellow at the Stimson Center and
columnist at foreign policy magazine and
author of the book oil the state and War
today we're going to talk about the war
in Ukraine that began almost a year ago
now with Russia's uh let me take this
down here
um thanks yep
with Russia's uh February 24th Invasion
on December 21st Ukraine's president
zielinski appeared before a joint
session of Congress to ask for more for
more money and weaponry which they did
deliver 45 billion dollars worth in the
latest Omnibus Bill so let's start off
the conver discussion with uh a quick
look at kind of the case that zielinski
was making to Congress a couple weeks
ago fertility
yes
thank you
we have it is it enough honestly not
really
to ensure
is not just a stronghold that holds back
the Russian army but for the Russian
army to completely pull out more cannons
and shells are needed thank you thank
you very much thank you for both
Financial packages you have already
provided us with and the ones you may be
willing to decide on your money is not
charity
is an investment in the global security
and democracy that we handle in the most
responsible way it is just a matter of
time when they will strike against your
other allies if we do not stop them now
okay so I mean the case that I hear
making there the two main points are
that we need more weapons to push Russia
all the way out and this is in your
self-interest America to maintain global
stability and norms and prevent Russia's
expansion uh from spilling into NATO
territory where you'd really be facing
the prospect of a World War
um so if we're looking at this you know
purely from a self-interested standpoint
it is he right
so I mean zielinski is a great orator
um and the case that he's making there
is I mean at least partly true in in
many cases true you know of the things
he said
um I think it's probably accurate to say
that that you know usaid to Ukraine over
the last year has not been charity that
we have got something out of it
um you know in terms of we've weakened
the Russian military
um we've prevented them from you know
helping to take over a country we we
have benefited from that um whether to
the extent that he means I think is a
bit more questionable
um where where I think you know I start
to differ with with some of the things
he said are you know he said that you
know if we don't stop Russia here
they'll come for U.S NATO allies
elsewhere in Europe that's I think a
pretty you know questionable assumption
um he talks about the need to push
Russians all the way out of Ukraine
um and I think that's the case for U.S
interests and Ukrainian interests might
quite clearly diverge over the coming
years
um and so you know I think what he's
giving us here is a partial picture
um and it's pretty true right now
because U.S interests and Ukrainian
interests are fairly aligned at the
moment
um but it may cease to be nearly as true
going forward and that's what I find a
little concerning
um you you know uh Emma you wrote a book
uh or a review on a book in foreign
affairs uh on realism
um and it seems like you have a lot of
sympathies with many of the realist
arguments
um just so we kind of you know you know
Nick and I are both coming from this
from a broadly libertarian perspective
and there's a range of foreign policy
used within the libertarian movement but
uh generally Libertarians tend to be
pretty skeptical of um getting involved
in conflicts that don't involve you know
a direct uh threat to the American
Security to American Security
um I'm curious you know just so everyone
kind of understands the lens that we're
all looking at this through what is
foreign policy realism and what aspects
of it do you find most appealing and
kind of our most applicable to the way
you look at things
really great question so um you know in
the time I've spent a few amount of time
around Libertarians I worked to Cato for
a number of years
um and in in that time I've sort of come
to see that you know I think there's
sort of two kinds of of Libertarians or
two kinds of Liberty friendly ways you
can think about foreign policy um one is
I think the classic anti-war approach
right that's very much philosophical
very much pacifist
um you know I I would say for myself I
certainly don't fall into that camp but
I know there are people with very strong
principles in that camp um I think the
other sort of way you could approach
this is much more consequentialist
um and it's it's sort of taking a more
realist approach to the world right so
you know we shouldn't abandon morals but
America can't necessarily be everywhere
and do everything we need to think about
our national interest and we need to
think about how to best achieve American
interests in a world that is sort of
quite difficult and becoming more
difficult for us to do so
um so for for realists you know you
don't care as much about so
International institutions you don't
want to do lots of humanitarian
interventions you're not trying to
spread democracy abroad all of those
sort of liberal internationalist ideas
instead you're basically focused much
more on defending American interests in
a limited way
um and doing so with the you know the
minimal force that we can do it so you
can see how anti-war folks and realists
get along in many cases because they're
pushing in the same direction but
they're coming at it for different
reasons
would you uh you know what what is the
big issue at uh you know a big American
interest that issue then in Russia's
invasion of Ukraine is it that it will
destabilize Europe is it that it will
um any time end internationally
recognized border is transgressed that
itself is you know some cause for
support if not outright um you know
military defense on somebody what what
is the key American interest
um that you see you know raised by uh
Russia's actions
yeah so I think there's a couple um so
one is I think as you say this this
question of sovereignty right this
question of changing territorial borders
by force um now I mean this is something
that the US has violated this Norm as
well
um over the last couple of decades
um and I think it's damaging every time
it happens whether it's Russia whether
it's the us and we should we should be
trying to avoid this so I I do think
there's something to be said for
discouraging the idea internationally
that big states can gobble up their
neighbors
um you know and I think there's also
something to be said for the fact that
Ukraine is you know a relatively
western-leaning
democratizing State
um again defending itself against a much
larger neighbor and one which borders
countries that the US has committed to
defend through treaties
um so for all of those reasons I think
some U.S support to Ukraine has
definitely warranted
um but those interests are limited right
that's not an absolute commitment to say
and Marines U.S Marines to push the
Russians back out of Ukraine at the cost
of World War III that's a limited
interest in hey we should probably send
them some weapons and funds um in you
know until the point at which that
becomes problematic for our interests
well I think uh we should dig a little
bit into those numbers to better
understand whether or not we've reached
that point or we're approaching that
point
um or whether this is kind of just a
Justified uh you know amount of Aid that
we've we've sent over there so far
um you know the this was from you know
last year uh about 48 billion dollars uh
worth of Aid uh you know a little less
than half of that was for weapons
um and other you know military assets uh
we just had the Omnibus Bill uh another
you know 45 billion uh approved there
um this is kind of the amount of a
that's gone to Ukraine versus other uh
Ally other U.S allies obviously the the
biggest recipients the U.S you can see
here is by far the largest funder of of
Ukraine in this conflict
um although if you break it down by GDP
uh Sheriff GDP some of the Eastern
European countries um have put far more
of their you know national GDP into uh
funding Ukraine and obviously uh really
stepped up to take a lot of refugees the
the millions of refugees that have uh
fled from there
um and then uh this is just a look at
the dod budget uh and you know Defenders
of uh
giving this Aid to Ukraine will point
out that it's a it's a fairly small
chunk of the overall budget that has
gone to Ukraine
um and so therefore you know in in the
big picture
not that much has gone to Ukraine they
will they would say uh We've offloaded
even you know old weapons that we're not
going to use anymore haven't had to
commit our own troops and so this is
kind of uh a bargain for the U.S tax
taxpayers is that a fair argument um or
is there uh you know a case that we've
we've gone too far
um you know funding this
yeah I mean so again I think there's
there's some truth to that argument that
you know this is a bargain I mean if you
told a lot of people a couple of years
back that we could have permanently
weakened the Russian military or you
know semi-permanently weakened the
Russian military in Europe for a decade
um at this cost they would have said you
were crazy right so it's I mean it's a
relative bargain in great power
competition Stakes um that doesn't
necessarily make a good idea though and
so I I think there's kind of four four
big problems we should talk about when
we talk about the aid um you know three
of them are kind of tactical issues and
then the fourth is a bigger strategic
problem um so the first one is as you
say
um the balance between the US and Europe
is a bit lopsided it is getting better
um and if you look at committed Aid
right so what states say they're gonna
send it's in theory going to get better
in the future
um that may not actually happen
um but yeah it would be good to see
European States um I know you know
they're suffering with the energy crisis
they're suffering with refugees but
still they're much closer to the problem
it's much more important to them they
should be spending more in the U.S so I
think that's that's kind of a really
obvious one
um a second problem is you know on
military aid at least we're starting to
see some Supply problems right we are
drawing down our own stockpiles
um and the U.S defense industrial base
um for all that it earns billions and
billions of dollars a year um it's not
actually very good at producing these
things fast
um and so at some point we're going to
start drawing down important stockpiles
for our own military and that's a you
know that's a concern that's something
that that we should be aware of
um the third problem and this one is you
don't hear about this quite as much in
the in the media but I I think it's
interesting to look at that chart to
talk about financial or fiscal aids to
Ukraine
um because right now with the war going
on the Ukrainian government basically is
reliant on foreign aid to fund all of
its government services you know they
can't tax the people easily in many
areas of the country there's active
fighting they don't don't know where
people are so um the Ukrainian
government is heavily heavily dependent
on that direct financial aid
um and I think you know the The
Economist Adam Adam twos has put it this
way he says you know Ukraine might win
the military war and lose the financial
war and I think that's you know we need
to ask ourselves how long do we want to
keep you know supporting just the
Ukrainian government with you know
checks that's that's another issue and
so that leads into I guess the fourth
issue which is the big issue which is
you know we can quibble about what we're
spending now um but it clearly can't go
on forever and so the question is when
do we stop this when do we encourage the
ukrainians to move towards the
negotiating table when do we see sort of
enough is enough we're not going to fund
you to take back Crimea
um and those are very difficult
questions with a moral Dimension as well
as with this financial Dimension um but
but to be honest I think that rather
than quibbling about the amount right
now that's the question it's how long
long does it continue for and how do we
think about dialing it back down to a
reasonable level over time what's your
sense of that what you know should those
conversations be happening now and
should we be pressuring zielinski and
Ukraine to figure out a way to come to
some kind of end to this
and again it's really
really because nobody wants to say
cranians off I don't want to say that I
think that would be a that would be a
terrible thing to do
um but we should now I think be having
conversations at least you know inside
the US between the US and its European
allies about the extent of that support
right how far are we going to push this
do we have plans for how to try and
actually move away from this conflict
because what concerns me right now is
you know I this this reminds me a little
of some of the debates over Afghanistan
right we are you know we've had this
period of what was in many ways a very
Justified conflict right we we have you
know met our national security needs but
we're slipping down the slippery slope
into something else and I would hate to
see this just become you know every year
we contribute 50 billion dollars to
Ukraine
um and so you know we should be thinking
about the places where we could make it
easier for the zelinski government to
consider opening negotiations right so
it may be that pressure from the U.S
might actually help zielinski publicly
in doing that
um we should be thinking about you know
the limits of support we should be
thinking about if we see a ceasefire on
the ground if we see a stalemate on the
ground is this the time to start
suggesting that we move towards
negotiations and so it's a really
difficult question and I don't think
we're quite there yet but we're not
talking now yeah what about Russia um
you know Russia is the clear aggressor
here
um you know and we can talk and maybe we
should about uh you know the various
actions really over the past you know
since the end of the Cold War that
America has either taken or enabled that
might make Russia a little bit more
jumpy and things like that but there's
you know there's no question Putin
decided to invade at a particular time
we levied uh really kind of
unprecedented sanctions unpre
unprecedented peacetime sanctions
against the country against Russia at
the beginning of last year
um is that working or what should we be
doing to
Putin and his regime to say hey you know
what uh maybe it's time you're obviously
losing here anyway maybe it's time you
get to the negotiating table
so one of the reasons I think why our
debates in Washington get so wrapped
around the question of the U.S will
pressure zielinski to end the war is
because we don't have that much leverage
on the Russians we just we have much
more leverage on the ukrainians than we
do on the Russians in this context
um we have as you say we've applied a
lot of sanctions quite heavy sanctions
they're taking their toll I mean they're
causing quite massive economic damage
inside the Russian economy
um but what they're not doing is
stopping the war and we've basically
seen already that Putin is has been
willing to escalate quite substantially
instituting a draft of people into the
military from Russia annexing provinces
talking about how this is you know going
to be a bigger war that we fought as
long as needed um so he's escalated
right even despite all of these costs
and that to me suggests that you know we
we probably have some leverage
um we could talk about sanctions relief
as part of a package you know for for
the Russians but it's not clear to me
that we have the ability to compel them
to come to the negotiating team I just
don't think we do to talk a little bit
more about the geopolitics obviously
India and China are the two biggest
countries that were like you know what
we don't care about American sanctions
we don't care about Western sanctions is
there anything that we should be doing
um you know on on either allies or
trading partners like China places like
India to be like hey what you know you
got to help us out here or is that just
you know a dream scenario that the U.S
would restore order in Europe by
pressuring you know people in other
parts of the globe
yeah so there's basically two approaches
to to sanctions um the one is you can
take the approach that the Obama
Administration took prior to the jcpoa
which is you build this big
International Coalition of states that
have some interest in you know in that
case of stopping around getting a
nuclear weapon
um the other alternative is you go the
sort of trump Administration group if
you just apply U.S sanctions extra
territorially on everybody
um the real problem is right we're not
talking about small concessions from
these states if you're talking about
trying to stop Chinese Russian trade
that is huge if you're talking about
stopping India from importing Russian
oil that is not going to happen
um and so you know you're talking about
serious pain for these states
um I don't think the economic potential
angle is likely to work at all what I do
think might be more effective though is
trying to get those States on side in
the Diplomatic space you know right now
um the Biden Administration is sort of
lumping together China with Russia
um and saying well you know China is
supporting Russia and this is bad
um they are sort of castigating the
Indians for continuing to buy Russian
oil my inclination instead would be to
try and bring those countries in and say
hey we all have some interest in seeing
this conflict end
um you know what are you willing to do
about it we've already seen signs I
think in public meetings between Putin
and she and Putin and Modi that they
actually do want this to happen so you
know there's a there's a coalition a
coalition they're ready to be built I
think the Gap that is uh troubling that
is it's not clear to me how it will be
bridged is just the question of the
territory that Russia has taken already
uh along the border and Ukraine has uh
you know pushed them back uh somewhat
out of a few of these territories
um but you know zelenski put out his
10-point peace plan and one of those
points is total withdrawal of all
Russian troops from all of Ukraine and
you've heard from members of the Biden
Administration even Biden himself at
some points has said basically we are
going to fund Ukraine as as long as it
takes for Russia to get out
um on the other hand Russia has claimed
that they've annexed these four
territories along the border and in a
speech uh I think it's worth playing a
little bit of this speech from Mark
Millie the chairman of the joints use of
Staff who lays out kind of the military
reality for both Russia and Ukraine at
this point and I'd like to just talk
about what he's laying out here whether
you you agree with his assessment and if
he's right you know what that means in
terms of pursuing pursuing real
negotiations at this point of Russia
achieving its strategic objective the
probability of Russia achieving its
strategic objectives of conquering
Ukraine of overrunning Ukraine the
probability of that happening is close
to zero the military task of militarily
kicking the Russians physically out of
Ukraine is a very difficult task and
it's not going to happen the next couple
of weeks unless the Russian army
completely collapses which is unlikely
so in terms of probability the
probability of a Ukrainian military
victory defined as kicking the Russians
out of all of Ukraine to include what
they Define or what they claim as Crimea
to the probability of that happening
anytime soon is not high militarily
politically there may be a political
solution where politically the Russians
withdraw that's possible
the problem what I
hear I'm saying there is that he's
almost you know laying out a stalemate
type of situation here where Russia's
you know they clearly like the the art
did not achieve their objectives they
did not just you know Mark March into
Kiev and take over everything over on
the other hand he's thinks extremely
unlikely that uh Ukraine any time in in
the in the near future is is going to
get them out of these contested
territories and then you know there's
the question of Crimea which uh does not
seem like on the table at all is
something that's going to go back in
into Ukraine at this point so given that
military reality
um is you know seeding to some of
Russia's you know territorial claims
going to be a necessary part of the
equation because it's not something I
ever hear anyone in the United States
government
um talking about
yeah I mean I I think Millie is right I
know he got castigated for saying it but
you know you can't predict what's going
to happen in a war you can say you know
probability wise you know these are the
scenarios that we're looking at these
are the ones that are likely um you know
and I think you know some of the
scenarios that are out there that are
just entirely unlikely are as he said
you know Russia conquering ukrainianism
is is almost entirely unlikely
um Ukraine pushing the Russians at
Crimea very unlikely the Russian
government collapsing or they're being
regime changed not impossible but
incredibly unlikely
um and so then you're left with the
scenarios that basically have some
variant of the ukrainians keep their
Advance going and manage to reclaim some
territory in the east of the country and
then you know we start talking or the
Russians turn around claim back some of
the territory they just lost and then we
start talking
um and so to my mind you know basically
if you want to actually end the war with
a peace settlement with a assist fire
with a process of some kind you have to
talk about territory um we could just
let it turn into a stalemate like the
Korean Peninsula but again that doesn't
seem like a good idea so we are at some
point I think gonna have to talk about
territory even if it's just Crimea even
if it's just the territories that
Russia's held since
um you know since its invasion of
Ukraine in in uh
2014. yeah can we uh follow up on that I
want to go to a question that was asked
by our uh audience member ocox he says
uh or they say talk about the 2014 coup
Victoria Newland bio Labs mints two
Accords killing and oppression of the
russian-speaking population by the Kiev
or Kiev regime for the last nine years
why don't we start with uh I mean pick
and choose from that what you find most
uh relevant here but what you know what
is the role of the 2014 regime change in
in Ukraine and the American role in that
what does is that important here or
should we not even bother kind of
remembering that anymore
it is difficult
sometimes to disentangle conspiracy
theories from reality there's some truth
to a few of these things many of them
are not true
um but I think you know the 2014
um governance change in in Kiev is
important because it's part of how we
got here right it's the same thing as
NATO expansion
um which definitely helped to bring us
to a place where a Russian invasion was
possible even as if you know as you said
that earlier the Russians chose this
yeah I mean so I if if I may say just
because I know you know a lot of
Libertarians talk about this stuff in
ways that I you know I understand where
they're coming from but I also find a
kind of insane making where they'll say
well the reason you know what Russia is
doing now is a defensive measure
effectively because the U.S you know was
talking about expanding NATO and and the
EU is talking about expanding what else
could you expect Russia to do for you
know a million years they've been
worried about exactly what we
telegraphed were doing and then we
either help or are in the more kind of
fervent imaginations of people we
actually replaced a democratically
elected government with you know one
that would be a puppet regime for us but
um you know Russia is the clear
aggressor here
this is part
icularly unhelpful to assign State's
modality in the first right states do
things that they think could end their
interest and sometimes they're horrible
and heinous and immoral and this is one
of those cases Russian leaders clearly
think it's important to them to control
some of Ukraine stop it slipping towards
the West even if we think that's kind of
abhorrent
um the the part of the question that I
guess I would come back to and talk
about a little because I think it's
relevant is the question about you know
the minska cards um and the relationship
between the West and East of Ukraine
over the last sort of decade leading up
to the conflict
um the Minsk Accords where a deal you
know the French and the Germans helped
to negotiate it with the Russians and
the ukrainians and the idea was that the
territories Russia took in 2014 would be
reintegrated into Ukraine but with
significant federalism right so that
they would be able to resist you know
language changes or education changes or
things they didn't like coming out of
Kiev and it was never put in place um
and both sides the ukrainians and the
Russia questions basically refused to
take the steps that would have been
necessary
um and so the reason I bring it up and I
say it's relevant is because I see
similar things being proposed now as
solutions to this conflict
um you know that if we just start
talking about federalism
um if we just start talking about you
know ways to integrate these territories
back into Ukraine that that will somehow
solve the problem
um that has been tried and it failed and
I do not see it succeeding in the future
how do you
um what is the danger of
um you know one one danger of kind of
endlessly pouring weapons into a country
like Ukraine is is a you are kind of
prolonging some something that uh is
ultimately you know if we're to believe
Millie's assessment kind of playing out
to a kind of stalemate and causing all
this death uh and just needless death
and destruction when really the emphasis
should be on diplomacy but then also the
you know you're you're just increasing
the likelihood that something truly
horrible and like an existential threat
is going to emerge you know a couple
months ago there was this kind of scary
moment where Biden himself was saying
we're like closer to a nuclear exchange
than we have been since the Cuban
Missile Crisis
um that Putin since then has kind of
like backed away from his nuclear
threats but it you know anytime you're
dealing with a nuclear power like that
like this is that
um you know something that should be
given more consideration uh in this
debate uh in terms of the types of Aid
and weaponry that we're sending over to
Ukraine
conflict
um I think they were more of a concerned
earlier on
um I think it was very clear you know
that first month of the war was
extremely dangerous
um and then escalation risks sort of
fell off again they've been up and down
a little but I mean at the point we're
at now we're sort of debating you know
will sending tanks versus armored
vehicles to Russia be enough of an
escalation for them to go nuclear and
you can kind of see that's like that's
like little Stakes no that's not a real
question
um versus early on when it was well
should we send Aid at all will that
prompt a response so but just because
escalation risks are lower now doesn't
mean that we shouldn't care about it and
that is one of the costs to American
National Security of continuing to fund
and arm Ukraine you know for some
indefinite period if it was just as you
say the question of prolonging the war
um you know I might deplore that that
notion that the war will go on longer
but equally I have a lot of Sympathy for
the ukrainians who are basically
fighting this invasion you know fighting
for their freedom
um I feel like in some ways that's their
choice to make about how long they want
to fight
um but then it's a it's the the decision
of American policy makers the American
public
how much we want to support that how
much it's in our national interest to
continue to support them and whether the
continuation of the war ends up hurting
us more than it helps and so you know we
have different national interests from
the ukrainians um so that's why again I
don't think the prolonging the war
question is particularly relevant if
you're sitting in Washington
but there's another
um kind of escalatory question that
pertains to the the type of weapons that
are being sent over because it seems
like the the Weapons Systems keep
getting more and more sophisticated that
that are being sent over and kind of the
most recent one is this uh Patriot
missile system and I've I've pulled a
couple clips of Biden and also uh Chris
Murphy who's on the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee talking about this
because one issue with that system is
that it involves uh you know American
soldiers having to train ukrainians on
it and that's you know not getting you
you American soldiers directly involved
in the war but it's getting them closer
and closer to the uh theater of war
there um so let me play these clips and
have you react to the question of you
know what the the types of Weaponry that
the US is sending over there if there's
kind of some hard lines that should be
drawn on or if we're creeping up to
those lines how the U.S calculated the
escalatory effect of sending a patriot
missile battery to Ukraine I did not
discuss that at all with the with the
president but I we do not it's a
defensive system purely defensive
systems and it is simply a response to
war crimes that are being perpetrated by
Vladimir Putin the reality is these are
complicated systems as you know and it's
going to have a long lead time to get
these up and running we are going to
actually have to send some American
troops over not to Ukraine but to places
in Germany and Poland to train
ukrainians so this does obligate more
American forces to be in and around that
theater and we just want to be clear
with the American people that with the
Patriots comes additional U.S forces
that are going to be close to this
conflict I just think the uh the the
cost to the United States is worth it
so do you agree with uh Chris Murphy on
that that the the cost is there's a
there's some risk but the cost is is
worth it
looks are relatively small at least in
the context of Patriots that there are
other systems that might start to go up
to the level of strategic stability at
the nuclear level that might be more
problematic but no one's talking about
those for that reason
um I think he's generally correct that
the risk of sending the systems
themselves is pretty low
um for me I think the red line the thing
I'd be incredibly concerned about is
starting to see U.S forces inside
Ukraine itself
um even if it's just for the purposes of
training right because kind of we all
know how that goes after two decades of
the war and Tedder they're there they're
training you know they get attacked and
suddenly they're fighting or maybe
special forces are there and so that to
me is a very slippery slope that's hard
for the public it's hard for lawmakers
to keep track of
um and so that's something we should we
should be avoiding um but the more
systems that go you know the more you're
going to start to see pressure to train
ukrainians kind of in-sit you inside
Ukraine instead of requiring them to go
elsewhere in Europe to be trained and
then the other thing that there will be
some U.S forces sent for is trying to
track where all these weapons are going
right because we're flooding Eastern
Europe with weapons
um and trying to keep track of that
without people on the ground is almost
impossible so you know those are those
for me are the areas of concern more so
than this specific weapons system or you
know the armored fighting vehicles or
whatever we're talking about this week
well I mean that that kind of gets into
another criticism that I've I've heard a
lot from the more you know purest uh
non-interventionist which is like
America is falling into this familiar
pattern of handing a bunch of weapons
and trainings to groups some of them you
know not the most Savory characters uh
Ukraine uh is fighting for its you know
uh independence from Russia but there's
all it's not exactly a liberal Paradise
you know zielinski has uh imposed media
censorship laws there's
um this kind of ongoing religious
freedom issue with the Orthodox Church
there's the the azov Battalion which has
uh you know neo-nazis in it and that you
know this is
you know the the worry that
non-interventions often have is that
this is going to come back to bite us
we're going to train up these groups and
give them these weapons that in the long
run we we don't want them to have
um is that uh you know a well-founded
fear um or is that kind of grafting a
situation from the you know Afghanistan
and Iraq uh which so much of us had had
our our kind of like uh foreign policy
Paradigm forged in onto a totally
different situation
no I mean I think it's a general concern
that you can basically port to almost
anywhere frankly that there's a war
going on
um I will say I do think in Afghanistan
and in Iraq that problem was
substantially larger right many more
groups many more avenues for smuggling
weapons out the country
um surrounding states in Afghanistan and
Iraq were themselves not always peaceful
um you know nobody nobody thinks we're
going to get an Insurgency in Poland
right because of this
um so you know there are there are
serious differences
um and but and I do think we should be
concerned about these groups
um the Ukrainian government though um is
I looked up as Freedom House score just
there which is a decent proxy it's about
60 which means it's partly free
um it has reasonable political and civil
liberties
um you know it's it scores badly in a
few areas but it has been improving in
recent decades so none of this means
that it's a democratic Paragon virtue
um none of this means it couldn't
backslide but at least for the moment I
think you know we should be we should be
very cautious about seeing the Ukrainian
government is is anything other than
sort of an a legitimate developing
democracy and then of course the US
should bring pressure on the Ukrainian
government as much as possible to
distance itself from groups like The as
of Battalion which they're a very small
proportion but you know we should be
bringing pressure do you see any sign of
that and I guess maybe excuse me we can
enlarge this to uh kind of a critique or
a question analysis of Joe Biden's
foreign policy uh he had a major you
know he gave a kind of major picture
that you commented on of his foreign
policy uh in the fall and you talked
about it uh you know his uh National
Security strategy as the lean in of the
NSS have it all uh one of our
questioners or listeners uh Tyler
Sherman said what effective discussion
points can we have with our friends who
argue that every Global event is in the
interest of U.S national security or the
economy
um Biden seems to kind of be like well
yeah everything is can you uh pull back
a little bit to talk about Biden's
larger strategy
um as such as it is and how how is that
guiding our Ukraine policy
yeah so the Biden Administration has
actually been fairly interesting early
on they showed I think some serious
signs that they were considering
actually reforms to U.S foreign policy
the withdrawal from Afghanistan is the
most obvious
um But as time has gone on their foreign
policy has kind of reverted to the mean
um to the extent that the National
Security strategy basically looked I
mean very similar to the Trump one very
similar to the Obama one to the George W
bush one
um which all worked out pretty well so
maybe you know when something's working
you don't mess with it right
well they they all kind of I think buy
into this notion
um and Bob Kagan had a piece in foreign
affairs last week that basically
explicitly stated it as you know if the
US
doesn't protect something whether it's
whether it's Iraq whether it's
Afghanistan whether it's Libya whether
it's Vietnam whether exactly right then
everything falls apart and I think you
know we need to we we need to be clear
about making the point that that is a
fairly absurd argument you know most of
those cases all of those cases
everything didn't fall apart when the
U.S failed to achieve its objectives and
and that's the second part of it right
that the U.S thinks it can just go in
and and hold everything together I mean
we're you know King Canute with the
waves or something and this is a popular
I was just gonna say it's not a popular
argument the American people arguing
first of all that America is not perhaps
quite as capable as you think of
affecting change in the world not
popular
um and then saying that we have to
prioritize and sort of decide where to
spend our scarce energy that's not
popular either but but they're vital
points yeah can I ask I mean because and
you know it's it's basically been a year
it's coming up on a year of uh you know
since Russia invented Ukraine and one of
the things that was striking in the
immediate aftermath of that happening
there was a broad demonization not
simply of Putin and the Russian
government uh which makes sense but
things like you know uh uh you know we
we saw stories about how orchestras were
getting rid of playing Russian music uh
you know certain types of Russian goods
were being
um you know uh boycotted even those one
you know even many of which did not they
simply had Russian names but they're not
from Russia a kind of World War One
mentality where people were going nuts I
guess
um you know my in in a kind of weird
jingoism my question is how did we so
quickly I mean we had not even fully
evacuated out of Afghanistan where some
suddenly the U.S was plunging into what
it considered a good War one that was
you know not morally obtuse but clear in
our you know everything that was good
and great about America is exemplified
by us going to the aid of Ukraine
um you know how where does that come
from and how do we combat that you know
not in the interest necessarily of some
kind of extreme isolationism but Justin
like I mean we just spent 20 years
[ __ ] up you know major parts of the
world and now we're like okay you know
now we know what we're doing we're going
to start playing in in Central Europe
you know I think it might even be
simpler than that I think it's um you
know we we did just spend 20 years
screwing up a lot of the things we
touched in foreign policy it's kind of a
relief to get back to you know disliking
the Russians and trying to thwart them
right so there's an element of I think
the cold war was the good War America
won it you know getting back to that
after the messiness of the last few
decades is I think a relief for many
people you know they wouldn't put it
that way but that's fundamentally what's
going on
um the problem is of course we're not in
the Cold War anymore
um it's not the same world it's not just
the US versus the Soviet Union you know
we also have the threat or the rise of
China
um we're talking about areas like Africa
Rising in different ways um and so you
know it's a very different world and I
worry that sort of just picking up our
mental model of the Cold War and trying
it back on because you know that's
that's what we feel good doing
um is a very bad way to to approach
foreign policy going forward it came it
seems like that's what the Biden
Administration is trying to do with this
sort of democracy versus autocracy
struggle framing that they're presenting
which is surprising since you know Biden
is so young and forward-looking in all
of his thinking that he would just
merely adopt a cold war Paradigm I mean
it's it's telling us I guess that at the
beginning of the war on terror Donald
Rumsfeld and it's kind of hard to
remember that Rumsfeld is now you know
I'm not only dead but you know 20 years
you know out of power almost or you know
whatever 15 years he explicitly said the
war on terror was a new Cold War
um where do you see a different
framework that is actually geared
towards kind of geopolitical reality
today that is not just kind of huffing
the fumes of the Cold War and you know
to to a certain degree that that is also
a critique of isolationists um you know
there were a lot of people during the
Cold War some Libertarians but a lot of
people on the way left who you know
essentially posited that the Cold War
was a an American construct in order to
kind of legitimize American hegemony all
over the place they're kind of stuck in
a cold war Paradigm too where you know
do you see any place in political power
where people are coming at this from a a
perspective that actually reflects you
know what has happened in the decade
since the Soviet Union collapse
I think we've seen a significant amount
of change not not perhaps across the
political Spectrum but you know at least
within both political parties we have
seen some more debate in recent years on
foreign policy and the emergence of
things that you might see in the future
developing into a better foreign policy
more suited to this world
um you know on the left we've got
Progressive Democrats
um who you know is they're very
internationalist in their view but
they're also very wary of American power
and so I think that's you know that's
good that's something that that should
be encouraged
um on the right we've got this the rise
of sort of you know you might call them
like hawkish
Jacksonian Republicans so you know
Donald Trump the people like Matt mates
Ted Cruz who you would not call doves by
any stretch of the imagination but
they've at least walked back from the
sort of you know we will remake the
world America's image stuff so these
these changes are happening but they're
painfully slow so it's going to be a
long time I think before they develop
into something more coherent to the
place the current consensus I'm curious
what you think that tendency on where
that tendency on the right in particular
is going to go uh there was just an
article in reason today by Bonnie
Christian about the kind of gopiers who
are against uh continued funding of the
Ukraine war and
um you know she raised the point that
it's sort of there is a sort of
incoherence to it that they're just on
this one issue uh taking a more uh
non-interventionist or maybe even
realist person perspective but it
doesn't seem to extend to any other
realm is that right or do you see that
um you know what's happening on the
right with people like you know Matt
Gates or you might look to somebody like
uh Rand Paul for a more like you know
principled uh non-interventionism and
within the Republican party what do you
expect that to develop into or what what
I guess what what's the best case
scenario that that could develop into
so yeah right so there's a worst case
scenario here which is that even though
those folks are you know want to get out
of the Middle East are wary of
subsidizing European Defense right that
they turning it as an a war with China
and so that's I think the worst case
scenario
um that the best case scenario though I
think is that you see the emergence of
you know on both right and left
um a somewhat more restrained foreign
policy so
um those folks on the right that have
been skeptical of Ukraine they're the
ones that are also somewhat skeptical
about spending on European Defense um
pushing for a more burden sharing with
Europe and I think that's a notion that
could catch on pretty easily among the
conservative Grassroots if it were
pushed by folks in Congress if you then
were to tie that up with a Democratic
party that actually starts to move in a
more Progressive Direction in foreign
policy you know you could find yourself
in a place where you have a pretty
stable bipartisan at least understanding
that the US is no longer the unipolar
power that we're no longer going to do
everything in the world and from my
point of view that would still be better
than today's status quo even if it's not
everything I want
there's a what yeah
well I was just going to pull up uh one
of the uh questions that I think just
gets to one of the fundamental issues
that we could weigh in on from Blake
Jameson question to the panel why is
Russia doing what they are doing you
must first answer this question before
any conversation ensues
um I mean I guess my my take on it is
that this is is Russia trying to you
know create a little bit of a buffer
between itself and
um kind of the west or the NATO
countries it's uh there's these you know
ethnic enclaves in the Border regions
and it's trying to bring those back into
the fold and just uh it's it's uh you
know it's a secure it's it it views this
as
um you know creating kind of a security
buffer that that's my my general sense
of what's going on but I'd be curious to
hear what both of you you think you know
the the motivation of Russia and and
Putin in particular is here
I'll defer to you Emma you uh you you do
this for a living
well I'm curious to hear what you say
too but I I think I mean I think there's
a there's an element of Truth to that
right that this is you know if not
Russia necessarily trying to create an
explicit buffer zone of territory
um it's an attempt to stop further
encroachment
um not just by the US by the way by the
European Union into the area immediately
surrounding surrounding Russia um now
whether that is a correct assessment on
the part of Moscow you know perhaps not
perhaps the threat really isn't there
um whether this is the right way to do
it I think we can all say that was a
pretty stupid way to do it
um but it's a good question and the
reason I think is a really good question
is because it has lessons for other
areas America has been very used to for
the last 30 years basically being um
what realist was called the hegemon in
every region that is to say we pretty
much run the table in terms of military
superiority in every major region of the
world that's changing right we are we
are reverting to a world that's more
like the norm where there's a bunch of
states that you know can compete with
one another that have military
capabilities that can threaten the U.S a
little bit even if you know maybe they
wouldn't win a major war
um and so what we're seeing happening in
Europe right now we could easily see it
happen in Asia over Taiwan or over some
other incident and I think you know from
my point of view the lessons we should
be thinking about from Ukraine are the
ways in which we avoid
um getting to the point where that Clash
happens in Asia
well it I mean to pick up on that is
there anything that the U.S could have
done you know uh a year ago or 18 months
ago to prevent this from happening
because it also seems that I think this
is in some of your writings on the topic
you know obviously the Russian invasion
of Ukraine has a lot of determinants and
one of them is probably also uh you know
there is a long-standing desire for that
kind of buffer zone a fear of
encroaching but a collapsing economy in
aging autocrat who is either looking for
a legacy or a you know the Olympic Games
didn't work to deflect attention from
how poorly he has run Russia you know
maybe a hot War
um seems good things like that but you
know was there anything realistically
that the U.S could have done without
going all the way back to 2014 or the
breakup of the Soviet Union or you know
uh you know pushing Ukraine to uh get
rid of its nuclear weapons Etc you know
what what might we have done that could
have forestalled this
I mean that's the
that's the so from from my point of view
and I think lots of people will assess
this differently from my point of view
by the time we got to about January of
2022 last year there probably was not
very much the us could have done I think
at that point it was it was pretty baked
in
um but I think if you go even six months
earlier and you look at that Summit that
Biden and Putin had where they talked
about strategic stability
um the bike Administration came in and
sort of indicated they were willing to
talk to the Russians
um the Russians reciprocated but I think
what happened at that Summit was the
Russians decided that the US wasn't
interested in actually talking about the
issues it wanted to talk about you know
conventional arms in Europe
um the question of failing arms control
um what is going to happen to Ukraine
and Georgia and Moldova and the US
basically wasn't willing to even talk
about those issues
um and so you know I don't think it's
inconceivable that if we had been
willing to explore some of those issues
um that we might have been able to
forestall this and then certainly if you
go back further as you say you know you
go back to 2016 or so and you talk about
you know putting pressure on to try and
actually Implement these agreements
rather than getting distracted you know
there's there's definitely ways we could
have got off this train
um I just you know start of last year it
was probably too late
can I uh just to kind of take this basic
frame and then throw it into Asia and
you've written about this but you know
one one of the lessons uh of of the
Russian invasion uh and this was also
made manifest by you know 20 years of
American effectively American failure in
Iraq and Afghanistan but is that you
know superpowers with really big armies
kind of suck at invading and occupying
and and pacifying countries
um uh you know so that's good if China
you know that might be one of the
lessons that they're learning and their
army is less battle hardened than Russia
I mean that's one of the things that's
amazing is people early on in in The
Invasion were expecting Russia to really
roll through things because not only is
it a major Army but it it has battle
hardened uh commanders and and troops
and things that didn't work out
um but what you know what are the things
that the U.S can be doing now uh
assuming we want to to 4 or stall China
flexing in places like Taiwan or you
know uh just kind of completely
finishing the steamrollering of Hong
Kong and things like that
yeah I mean so you know we should
definitely hope that China's taking
lessons from Ukraine but I think we
ourselves should not assume that because
the Russian military was Hollow that the
Chinese military will be right very
different systems structured in very
different ways we just don't know how
effective the Chinese military is they
could be great they could be awful and
that's not something we can predict
right now
um where I think we can start to you
know to to think about getting on a
better track here is in the political
and diplomatic space right so right now
in many ways we are on a collision
course with China in Asia
um whether it's to do with decoupling
whether you know all these export
controls and things like that um or
whether it's on the question of you know
do we shift away from our long-running
approach to Taiwan and recognize them as
a state um you know do we send U.S
troops
um my concern is all of that just raises
the stakes and basically forces a choice
on the Chinese leadership
um if they want Taiwan to stay in their
sphere of influence then they will have
to do something about it and what we've
seen in Ukraine is that you know we
think that will deter other countries
but we may not like the choice that
leaders end up actually making
um so you know my my approach to Taiwan
would be mortal on the lines of help
Taiwan to arm itself for better defense
to make it self is unpalatable to China
as possible in an invasion and then just
try and find other ways to diffuse some
of those tensions um because I I do
think you know right now the situation
U.S China relations looks very much like
the situation in U.S Russian relations
10 years ago um and I'd hate us to end
up in the same place could I just ask to
follow up a little bit on that um what
is the role of the countries that
actually you know either surround or in
close proximity to targets like Taiwan
uh countries like South Korea countries
like Japan maybe even Australia uh in
Europe uh you know do you feel like you
know Poland Poland has certainly done an
incredible job of absorbing refugees and
and kind of helping be a pass-through
point for all sorts of things but our
Germany and France are the major NATO
countries
um and the European Union countries
pulling their weight or is that you know
um you know is is that a kind of
premonition of what might go wrong if
something analogous happens in Asia
probably shouldn't laugh when you say
are they are they cooling their weight
um
they're not pulling their weight the
polls are the estonians are the latvians
are the lithuanians are that the checks
are and that's because they're very
close to Russia right they're the
bordering states they feel the sense of
threat
um even with U.S protection and they
could definitely be doing much more
they're the ones stepping up on defense
um and the question is you know I think
with U.S presence there whether Germany
or France or other countries will ever
step up you know with the us there to
protect them and with them feeling a
relatively low threat from Russia
um in Asia I think what we're seeing is
actually a little more
um comforting from the point of view of
U.S planners which is the South Koreans
the Japanese the Australians they
actually all do see a threat from China
and even with some U.S presence they are
all actually trying to get more capable
in the military space
um so you know my my bottom line is I
want U.S allies to carry far more of the
burden for their own defense potentially
all of it at some point Point um but you
know I see more hope for optimism in
Asia than I do in Europe where um you
know after all the grand promises the
middle of the year last year we've just
reverted to form where the U.S pretty
much does everything
just to um kind of wrap up the stream I
want to return to the the the question
of the stream which is should America
keep funding Ukraine as we look ahead to
this new year and um you know obviously
a lot of
in some sense the question is like well
it's the or the answer is it's going to
keep funding Ukraine it's all the
fundings are even past the president has
the ability to kind of give uh you know
a very uh free hand to give Ukraine
weapons because of a previous bill
passed uh by Congress but what do you
hope like what is the
um the change in policy that if we want
to be hopeful that uh you hope
transpires over this next year
um to kind of at least if not totally
cut off Ukraine from funding at least
start to push Ukraine towards and right
to sorry to push Russia and Ukraine
towards some sort of uh resolution here
no I think that's a good way to frame it
the question really isn't should the US
end funding to Ukraine because we're not
going to and we probably shouldn't
anyway the question is you know are we
prepared to think about how we try and
end this conflict sooner rather than
later
um and that I think requires far less
attention by policy makers to what
specific Weapons Systems we're sending
the ukrainians or how much money and how
fast and more attention to actually
thinking about you know how long we want
to do this and what we're actually
willing to sort of take from you know
Ukraine in terms of progress right if
everything's stalemates now when there's
no further movement on the ground in
three months and six months you know is
that when we pressure strongly to come
to the negotiating table is that when we
try and use whatever carrots we might
have with Russia to get them to
negotiate so I think it's much more a
discussion about when we start to tape
it off or dial back that Aid and not
unless a discussion about yes or no
right now
do you in some way are we living in
Trump's World in terms of foreign policy
uh in the sense of he uh I mean you were
talking about as a kind of Jacksonian
Hawk obviously he's belligerent in his
personal Behavior he he wanted you know
he talked about that big beautiful
military with the best new weapons and
toys wanna spent a lot of money on it we
just had like a major National Defense
bill that is you know a peacetime record
or whatever but but he also did stress
the idea that the U.S isn't going to be
paying you know the price uh in literal
or figure of terms going forward and it
seems like even if Biden has committed
to a kind of idea of the U.S as the
still indispensable Nation he did you
know a year ago roughly or you know
ruled out American troops uh defending
or or being in Ukraine you know has was
Trump on to something with that and is
that to begin beginning of a pivot from
I'd like you know A Century Of America
being indispensable to the United States
being one player among many
I think you know I always laugh when
people say oh what what would Trump have
done if he was president during the war
in Ukraine because I don't think there's
any way to know the answer right my
suspicion is he would have left
zielinski uh to twist in the wind
because the man got him impeached one
time but that's much more you know if we
were to assume a president with Trump's
rough views in foreign policy but
without all his personal pathologies I
suspect the policy would look fairly
similar to what Biden's doing right now
you know arming Ukraine pushing the
Europeans to do more maybe not sending
all the troops um but yeah I suspect the
policy would look relatively similar to
what we're doing now and this is I think
the thing that gives me some hope in
foreign policy is if you look at the
trajectory from Obama through Trump to
Biden you do see you know fairly
significant changes in certain areas
right in you know we're pulling back
from regime change we're pulling back
from nation building
um the U.S is pushing burden sharing you
know 10 15 years years ago burden
sharing by allies was a dirty word in
Washington so things I think are
trending in the right direction in a
number of areas it's just very slow and
it's going to take I think a couple of
administrations before we start to see a
more complete package of Reform can I
this might be beyond your uh scope of
analysis or expertise but what the hell
you know when we look at 2024 and when
you look at you know somebody like a Ron
DeSantis or a governor you know Gavin
Newsom or you know the the Pres you know
presumptive
people who are going to be or Kamala
Harris for that matter is there do we
have any sense that these people have an
interest or an expertise in foreign
policy
um or are they going to be kind of like
Trump where he had certain instincts but
then you know kind of got rolled by the
uh by The Establishment
um you know is there is there any reason
to think a new generation of leaders is
is kind of going to come into place
which will kind of move into the 21st
century before it's over
I think the answer there is yes but I
don't necessarily think it's this next
Generation
Um Harris is fairly ill-defined in
foreign policy but one gets the sense
that she's closer to sort of the Hillary
Clinton wing of the party
um Rhonda Santos we actually know from
his his time in Congress and stuff he's
he's quite hawkish looks more like I'd
say like Mike Pence on foreign policy
then on then another possible you know
yes yeah so so that's more
neoconservative less Jacksonian
um so but but part of this is I think
that there's so much uncertainty with
you know both parties having obvious
presumptive nominees
um if you look a generation down and you
look at folks like um you know uh
Joaquin Castro Chris Miller rokana
um you know they all have more
interesting instincts on foreign policy
and so you know I think it's kind of a
generational shift um we're just we're
just not quite there yet
yeah yeah uh well uh thank you very much
for taking the time to talk it through
with us uh Emma and uh thank you Nick
and to all the viewers who tuned in
tuned in live and those of you listening
later uh we will be back uh again next
Thursday
great thanks so much